código rojo para la humanidad el planeta
se está calentando a un ritmo rápido
intensificado con impactos irreversibles
el calentamiento global es una realidad
sin retroceso según el informe de
expertos de naciones unidas'
en primer lugar nos dice que es
indiscutible que las actividades humanas
están causando el cambio climático y
haciendo que los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos sean más
frecuentes y graves en segundo muestra
que el cambio climático está afectando a
todas las regiones de nuestro planeta y
por último explica que se necesitarían
reducciones fuertes rápidas y sostenidas
de las emisiones de dióxido de carbono y
otros gases de efecto invernadero para
limitar el calentamiento global robo
gómez en las próximas décadas la
temperatura habrá subido al menos 15
grados por encima de los niveles
preindustriales incumpliendo a la
ambición del acuerdo de parís de 2015 y
provocando una devastación generalizada
por ello los activistas llaman a la
actuación de los gobiernos antes que los
científicos puedan elaborar informes
esperando pueden salvar el mundo sólo
pueden decirnos lo que está ocurriendo
esto depende absolutamente de los
gobiernos y sólo hay unos pocos
gobiernos críticos
realmente importante y novedoso del
informe es que señala como la influencia
humana está haciendo que los fenómenos
climáticos extremos como las olas de
calor las lluvias torrenciales y las
sequías sean más frecuentes y graves el
nuevo informe no se anda con rodeos a la
hora de esbozar las consecuencias
actuales de nuestro aumento de gases
efecto invernadero emisiones y de cómo
estas decisiones en las próximas décadas
conducirán a futuros climáticos muy
diferentes una reducción drástica de
emisiones puede evitar un cambio
climático peor pero no devolverá al
mundo los patrones climáticos más
moderados del pasado